i did want to ask you a hunger games
question because i'm also obsessed with
that franchise but
i'm really curious to know what it's
like making the decision
to do one project versus another what
what are some of the prime
factors that you have to consider when
making a big choice like that
i'm so happy to talk about this i was
asked about that recently
um because i i think there was some
stuff out at the time that was really
not
kind of accurate about it it was
actually quite it was so
simple what happened which was that uh
i was doing much to do about nothing in
the park with hamish
i think we had been planning it for
however long talking about it for
probably a few years uh and then it was
happening and it was set and
when i was cast in the hunger games the
dates worked with
with much ado um i think i was gonna
shoot it before
we started rehearsal and
for reasons that i can no longer
remember that had not absolutely nothing
to do with me but just to do with
production
the dates pushed on hunger games and
they pushed
a few times so at first we were still
fine then we were still fine
and then they pushed to the point where
uh
it wasn't even during our rehearsal
period it was actually during our
performance period and the park schedule
there are so
few performances they're so precious
it's why when it rains
we wait and we wait when we wait we go
on until you know the lightning is
shutting because we will do it in the
rain you just do not want to miss a
single one of those
performances they're so precious and the
rehearsal period is quite short too so
the whole thing
is really short and there are no
understudies and even if i had had an
understudy
you just don't want to give one up but
there aren't any and
um and it just got to the point where
there was no way for me to uh to do the
hunger games
and it wasn't even really uh
a battle it was just oh this no longer
works out and i have made this
commitment to do
much you do and and the hunger game
side they were all completely aware of
it and so
they so understood my choice and were so
supportive
um so there was really no drama it was
the only
sad thing was that i couldn't do both
but it wasn't uh
it wasn't as sort of oh which one do i
do because one had been my prior
commitment and um and everyone was
totally aware of that so
it uh it was unfortunate but it ended up
you know as i i suppose you know i um
i don't know i've never really it just
was what it was and when i couldn't do
both i couldn't do both
and uh
makes sense made sense i respect that
choice
i remember reading something like
there's no who whatever do you how do
you choose doing a plus no you know and
i was like well but that was my
uh i you know it was my commitment and
it was in my heart to play
to play beatrice with uh with hamish and
um and my god i would have loved to to
be a part of the hunger games i too am
such a fan
um but yeah well i was disappointed you
didn't take that end up getting to take
that role in the hunger games
i feel like one of the biggest
compliments ever is having to drop out
of a project like that and then having
gwendolyn christie of all people take
that role
she's incredible that's so flattering to
you too because she's wonderful you're
wonderful
so wonderful and amazing and i i love
the you know
i i'm so it everything you know
it was all fine